the Nevada State Legislature is meeting
for a special session this morning up in
Carson City lawmakers will address the
state budget which has been hit hard
because of coven 19 Orko mana is in
Carson City this morning with a preview
we are just hours away from a historic
special session here in Carson City
Nevada lawmakers are trying to fix the
state's 1.2 billion dollar budget
shortfall which is a result of the
coronavirus shutdown the state has no
choice but to make severe cuts to
services and programs in order to
balance the budget Health and Human
Services K through 12 education and
higher education are likely to be
impacted the most
governor steve says slack recently
released a list of his budget proposals
one idea is for each state agency to
slash their budgets by up to fourteen
percent which would make up about half a
billion dollars it's understanding that
everyone is going to have some of the
shared pain and shared responsibility is
I think the realistic approach and then
you know setting the priorities from
there over which programs need to be
most protected which populations are
most vulnerable we have to look at and
see what can turn back in order have the
programs continue services individuals
and then as Nevada recovers that we can
turn around those program plexiglas has
been installed in the Nevada Assembly
and Senate chambers and the public while
still able to chime in will not be
allowed inside the building both changes
a sign of the times once the budget
shortfall is tackled governor sissel Act
plans to put out another Proclamation to
address other issues potentially like
police reform reporting from Carson City
Orko mana 8 news now